here's a guy right here who got lost in
the hills behind your house
[Laughter]
hey there brenton theo everyone in the
kingdom
i'm jeremy from new zealand it's out
here taking your walk in this beautiful
day
god damn i've got to make up for you
and natural suntan all those artificial
hitters
[Music]
i like natural but only problem is
get those tan lines
what what's the other king you're seeing
veneers first of all there's an
avalanche coming out
yeah get going man [ __ ] the show get
going bro
yeah dude sun tan or regular tanning you
say oh word i thought it's not about
veneers
he's also talking about being buried
below ground or above ground apparently
without even knowing it
dude you can hear an avalanche coming
man if
he stayed calm cool collected dude you
got a reason you could see how the
corners i like that security guard you
had he's all
uh uh suntan
fake tan vs real tan oh that's what the
guy was asking
real tan always man just take your shirt
off so you don't have the farmer's tan
i always tell theo get them cheeks out
tan the buns bro
let the get the buns toasty son you got
to get a yard or something you can do it
i gotta
you know my apartment here has a roof
and i can go up there sometimes but the
neighbors
they they own the building yeah and i
don't think they're ready to see all of
that magic
that that farmer's tan is tough
dude and then especially when it's
around your neck and your neck and face
all tan
and then below that it's like pale as
[ __ ]
jimmy put on that [ __ ] fake tan i do
i actually have a subscription to it
so what do you mean what it takes you
don't look tan so there's no but you
tell them my upper half is way darker
than that i caught a glimpse
chin was one of these sweats and they
they hiked up a little bit and i saw his
cast
bro what are you guys talking about
chin is white and uses fake i use fake
tanner just to be normal which is news
to me
to be normal what are you talking about
you mean trying to fit in black history
month
i'm just so free i'm a ghostly white
it's so it's almost like translucent
it's gross
so how much do you put on like half a
handful no
it's a mister it's a l'oreal you put on
your face
a guy does it for you no i literally get
it on your back you spray it up and run
under it so here's the thing i only
spray stuff that shows so
my stomach is still white it's just my
arms my neck
what that dick do though
what do you mean dude yourself i'm just
straight by now you're gay i'm just
spitballing ideas here
do you spray the don't be spitballing
the wasabi stick you're talking about if
you spray the wasabi
no okay there there's chips yeah
i'm like black i'm not black i'm brown
and white you spray your face though you
go chocolate face no i tried doing that
before and it looks
so weird ooh i wish you could come in
here we could do it you can do it you
could go at least milk chocolate yeah
a nice caramel yeah i wouldn't do
anything with almonds in it
no i'm not supposed to be dark for some
reason i look really really strange when
i'm darker is your girl dark
she's very dark yeah man she's very
tanned what about dark koreans is that
something can you look at on
just look how powerful yeah koreans go
chocolate body chocolate face especially
in lifting competitions
let's look up some dark co-roses i don't
think they're gonna see any dark greens
well uh
cat's dark i know she's not korean but
she's asian she's there's one on the
far right check out the forehead on the
bottom right check out the klingon
that's definitely not korean that guy's
korean dude hold on
han him oh korean nigerian he's got some
nigerian
he's half black but see he's got
porridge
do you think he looks normal i mean he
looks fine but do you think he looks
there's something like looks a little
odd right
that's how i look
pretty fair-skinned people for asians
yeah pretty much
i get dark dark do you mexican dark
dude i got bit by a dog when i was
sunbathing when i was young so i have
really
i think for safety sometimes you've got
to go into the
tanning salon but if you're in a safe
area fenced in area or something i think
you can sunbathe
before ufc fights i just hit that
tanning bed
you did yeah man got to market the
product doug
and that body's the product baby
that was andre arlovski's philosophy too
he always he was worried about being
really jacked back in the day because he
knew that was part of it yeah
yeah you check all boxes daddy damn
i would like to see some of these guys
start to whiten up a little bit some of
the darker your white face
yeah that'd be cool i would like to see
israelis saying it get
more white i would like to see paolo
costo
get more white maybe maybe the black
anybody who shops at costco
the black beast maybe francis whitens up
a little bit
yeah i would like to see oh you want to
go i don't know if you want to go sammy
sosa though he went frank sinatra at the
end dude he got
really uh yeah he looks like the guy in
the godfather
it is a nightmare yeah he got he ended
up as ray leota that's how far he went
yeah
uh before smoking yeah he said uh he
just uses a lotion he didn't know who's
gonna do that
see that's what happens chin using a
spritzer now how do you get it on your
back
i don't that's the thing i only yeah so
it's definitely only right now
that's all i care about just so i can
look normal otherwise it's maybe like a
you do the feet too
i tried before but then it doesn't work
out well yeah
wow nick's the white student in here oh
yeah i'm spending a lot of
time in front of computers recently i
bet they're getting outside those thighs
and
ass are just what are you guys talking
about what is this show about
self-tanner if oozman did the whitened
up he'd be the nigerian white mare